I'm doing Moulin Rouge and to debrief
from the whole journey of Moulin Rouge I
said to see him look we just had a
little baby girl you go to Paris with a
little Lily and I'll meet you there but
I'm gonna do one of these bucket list
things I've got friends in Shanghai I'm
gonna go on the trans-siberian Express
and you know I'm gonna take some
Dostoyevsky and it's gonna be amazing
rejuvenation of my spirit and I poured
the wine and I had to recorded books on
an iPod one I can't remember what it was
but the other one was f scott
Fitzgerald's The Great Gatsby and I
remember when it finished just being
inconsolable about the loss that it was
over and most profoundly that I didn't
know that book at all I realised I
didn't understand it would seem
completely new to me and everything
about it the way it was written the
scenes in it the characters and I
thought that is us that is now that is
who we are and I could just work out how
to unlock the inner voice of Nick
Carraway there was a film to be made of
that book there was a way of doing a
film we are researched junkies we have
lived as elder and Scott for many years
now let's not talk about the champagne
cocktail part right but but really and
honestly every decision in his film has
come from Fitzgerald in MA in our
interpretation so for example Fitzgerald
was an extreme modernist you know he was
so interested in film he was so
interested in screenplays and he would
put film technique into his writing so I
was thinking you know I really if I was
kind of Fitzgerald and the first girl
was doing a film how am I what modern
thing would he go about doing and write
about then I was lucky enough to see him
I was at Warner's and I called up the
old reels of dial M for murder by
Hitchcock the drama was playing
out it wasn't exactly like theater but
it wasn't film either and it was
dramatically amplifying things it was a
dramatic amplification and I was
thinking about Gatsby which begins with
all this razzle-dazzle
but ultimately strips down to five
actors in a hotel just up the road here
just actors in a space that's that could
be incredible particularly actors at the
top of their game so I just thought I
know there's gonna be a lot of eye ball
rolling I know there's gonna be a whole
lot of can you just not do that but I
just thought I have to if it's gel was
going about it he would not walk away
from this new tool as a visual list I
mean in terms of being a filmmaker bass
uses all the techniques from working
with actors to script to music to the
image he is always thinking about what
is going to ultimately go on in the
picture plane so he can draw stuff for
me I think he scribbled a few things for
me he uses tear sheets and also kind of
philosophical perspectives that he is
approaching the work from to kind of
give me a starting point so one of the
fundamental things that he came to me
with he said I don't want the New York
that this story inhabits that we create
in the film to be a nostalgic New York I
don't want it to feel soft and
historical I wanted to feel as sexy and
contemporary and modern and visceral and
exciting and hard and all those things
as it would to the characters in the
book and to as it felt to Fitzgerald so
it it starts with sort of some
philosophical points of view some actual
imagery and then it's a whole process of
research and analysis of the source
material in fact through the archives at
Brooks Brothers I was able to deduce
that they
making seersucker suits sort of late
19th century early 20th century and that
actually made pink seersucker suits I
mean pink shirts have been in existence
for over a hundred years like all longer
actually and men will very colorful
shirts in the mid 19th century so all
those colors but anyway it came out of
the fact that Fitzgerald was a lifelong
customer that he mentioned it in his
books but it was really through the
research and from that point on I
decided it would be great to partner
with them to be able to give more
texture to the film I thought that it
would help to tell the kind to to
describe the kind of New York and the
kind of milieu that Gatsby inhabited
that we would have the luxury of having
clothes that were specifically made for
the background man you know Leonardo I
didn't think about it right I didn't
think about it because I work with him
when he was a young gifted boy he's now
a man he's fully in control of his
instrument as an actor he has natural
scream charisma he's also in my
estimation one of the greatest actors
that ever there were I know that
so he's obsessively because early on his
natural scream charisma got him a lot of
attention run away from that he's run
towards the complex he's run towards the
dark but the one thing that was really
clear I mean Fitzgerald
took african-american street music and
he put this jazz in the pages of his
text he put popular song in the text of
the Great Gatsby now look I love
traditional jazz I happen to have grown
up with a stepfather who had 14,000 jazz
seventy-eights of the period and 11,000
cylinders which people go what the
hell's a cylinder it's like you know
it's old anyway the thing is that I mean
I know maybe expired back and I love
that sound but the singular fact is if
you put that music that's in the text in
a film it's classical music I mean it's
wonderful but it's extremely charming
and I wanted to find a way to make the
film feel like what it was to read that
book in 1925
now you know people said why are you
doing it jazz is a fad it's gonna be
over next week Fitzgerald coined the
phrase the Jazz Age and it wasn't much
of a leap to go where we're living in
the hip hop age the idea was that when
the characters are hearing right but but
but you know we're hearing ba da da da
dum boom you know it was that
intoxicating it was that dangerous